توقفت منصه تيك توك في الاردن وما زال
الخلاف قائما بدايه لم يكن السيد غيث
متقبلا لتلك المساحه الكبيره التي حاضت
بها المنصه من حياه ابنائه واليوم يرفض
ابنائه غيابها اما هو فكان من اكثر
المرحبين بهذا الغياب انا بطالب بمواصله
ايقاف هذا التطبيق لانه زي ما حكيت مكان
لنشر التفاهه مكان للتحريض مكان للقتال
الخطاب الكراهيه ومكان لنشر الاكاذيب زي
ما فيها اشياء سلبيه فيها اشياء ايجابيه
وبظهر لكل شخص حسب اهتماماته لانه يعني هو
بضيع من وقت البني ادم مش انه بساعدك
بالعكس اساءه استخدام المنصه على خلفيه
احتجاجات مواطنين حول ارتفاع اسعار
المحروقات في الاردن كانت السبب في توقفها
منذ ثلاثه اسابيع وما بين رافض ومؤيد ان
قسمت اراء الشارع بس نفسي افهم ايش دخل
التيك توك بالي عم بتصير ليشطبوا يعني
تكتب كان شيء كثير بسلي
على الهاتف لكنه لا يعمل الا ان البعض ذهب
لمواقع في بي ان لفك الحظر ومتابعه من
الصدته التي اثر غيابها على وجوه اعتمدتها
لشهره ومصدر للرز
يزعل يشيل الخط الارضي او بس يزعل مني
يعني تقدر مثلا اذا في فيديو في فيديو
خارج النص يقدر تكتب
من زمان